voyez comme nous devrons dire qui la
prends comme un de ses fils puis deux
heures la main je sors un tout petit peu
claires
il abhorre
[Musique]
sous la couette nuit doc doc clock
d'avis une école tastavy partie
mécanique et
[Musique]
benoît le jour d'harcourt contre l'image
allez place
avec les années
elle brille
il
car j'ai excuse que ça a pu blesser chez
je l'avais la face à l'apathie qui vous
dit et je suis désolé ça va les chercher
et on a défoncé le plateau pour lui et
ça comptera téléspectateurs blessé tout
seul
[Musique]
de recevoir tenir le guidon élevé
jusqu'à ce qu'il atteigne la possession
des billets à temps c'est le levier de
blocage dans le sens de la fête voilà je
suis fréquemment comme ça toi tu avec
ses tons manière comme ça c'est bon
m
béchir est latente
[Musique]
moi je me suis relax la gare soir
le chemin doit calmer
[Musique]
on trouve le prochain
c'est bouleversant pouet
comme quoi il n'ya pas d'amour
impossible comme moi même décor
politique ça va être amoureux des
valeurs centimes en espagne est la plus
jeune j'écoutais un as possession des
flamands
avec eux
goodyear se présente à la présidence des
états unis
charlize theron
[Applaudissements]
oui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
quoi